this is a production of cornell
university
so this is this is a seminar for me to
re-up my adjunct status um i am a
research geneticist
plant
with usda ars
um and i think i think everybody knows
me so i'm not gonna give any details
from my cv or whatever
um
you know the faculty members will
receive my cv as well as a statement of
interest and you'll get to vote on me
um
since we're here in person i i
i failed to do this uh earlier last year
and this year which is to present the
murphy monger awards and so they're
actually three people up i'm not sure if
they're all on zoom with us now or here
in the audience but let's give them a
round of applause
[Applause]
congratulations
um and
yeah i'm just
i it turns out i have too much
information to give you and so i'm just
going to be barreling through
um
you know there'll be little interludes i
have a little four little vignettes so
maybe one question or two at the end of
each vignette uh but so yeah these are
some of my quantitative things
they make me happy
um
uh so so prediction about metabolites
additive relationship matrices for for
sugar kelp that has a biphasic life
cycle you know not just genomic
selection but genomic mate selection
and then the last thing that i'll spend
a little more time on is this bayesian
optimization of breeding scheme budgets
uh okay so the first one i'm they're
they're not really my quantitative
things they're definitely
uh it's work that's being pushed forward
by various postdocs and research
associates
um oats are a known healthy crop and so
this is in part due to secondary
metabolites uh and so breeders are
interested in being able to manipulate
the levels of these and so we've been
looking into that with with my gore and
and the main person responsible for what
i'm going to show you here is lauren
uh
so here's the premise of what we're
we're doing um the idea is okay so you
have some metabolite there are variants
that cause it to have different levels
if you have a handle on on the causal
loci
when you're estimating their effects you
want to estimate those effects from a
different distribution
than loci for which you have no evidence
of causality uh i thought malaga
campbell you know stated that really
nice
in his paper last year
and so the hook that we're using here is
when you do untargeted metabolomics you
get a lot of data and we want to try to
use that data more completely to um to
sort of prioritize uh loci according to
their probability of being causal
they're different possible approaches um
we have a discovery panel we could we
have metabolomics there we could match
one to one between metabolites and the
discovery panel and metabolites in the
prediction set
the thing that we're actually going to
try to do though is uh combine a series
of metabolites in the discovery panel on
the assumption that
by joining information from them
we'll get get a higher ratio of signal
to noise i guess uh for this
prioritization
then the other part is actually once
you've decided which loci you're
interested in is estimating their
effects we could estimate them directly
in the discovery panel
we're not doing that we're uh using just
the discovery panel for this
prioritization and then we're estimating
effects
in a downstream um prediction panel
so this is what this looks like to sort
of these different possibilities and
we're in that lower right hand corner
okay so how do we actually draw effects
from different distributions um if you
do let's see can people see this
uh if you do standard rr bluff you're
drawing all of the effects from the same
distribution it's a normal distribution
so alpha are the effects of the loci
uh it has one variance for all effects
and and we're using a fairly simple
approach we have loci that we have some
evidence that they're causal i'm putting
a subscript c
for those and we're pulling them from
one normal distribution it has a
different variance than the distribution
of the loci that are the rest of genome
loci so for which we don't have evidence
of causality and in principle
um
this variance component sigma squared c
should be bigger than the variance
component sigma squared r right
uh so so what what lauren has done is um
uh in the discovery panel to do g wasps
on all of the metabolites we have some
1600 metabolites
and then
uh she brings together sniffs that are
hit uh in in different ways um some
sets of snips are sort of general uh
um you know
across all of the metabolites the snip
is hit and and we choose snips that are
look important because they're hit more
than once
in other models we're bringing together
snips that hit metabolites of particular
structures so phenylpropanoids or lipids
and then
in a third set of models she brings
together snips that participate in
metabolites that are part of the same
pathway so terpenoid pathway
um the valinate pathway or this methyl
erythritol pathway
so there's sort of different levels of
specificity of these models
i guess the point though with these
models is that our idea is that or her
idea really is that they are capturing
different areas of the causal space uh
and so for any given metabolite in the
prediction set
if it if it's causal loci overlap with
the space that is captured by one of
these models it should be well predicted
by that model
on the other hand if it's if it's not if
it doesn't overlap if the cause of loci
for the particular metabolite say
doesn't overlap with his gc2 model then
it should be poorly predicted uh by that
model and so
what you're going to have for any given
metabolite is a kind of natural ranking
of the accuracies of these models
according to how well they capture the
the causal space of the metabolite
so
um then downstream in in the in the
prediction panel we we look at different
ways of
identifying which models uh might be
good to use the first way is requires
the sort of highest level of detail of
annotation uh for these metabolites so
it's oats and we're looking at specific
secondary metabolites that are of
interest in in oats
uh and these are avenanthromides uh vena
cosides and avenasins
and what you see is that um
compounds that have
the sort of same annotation that
presumably are part of the same pathway
are have a high correlation of the
ranking of the accuracies of these
models so if you have
loci that where you have detailed
information
uh you you can use that as a guide for
which model to use
the second approach is to use um
chemical structures of the metabolites
and this is sort of a terrible slide uh
you can't really tell anything from it
but focus just on the colors i hope you
can see the colors in uh in the labels
of this column
and basically these are different lipids
uh we've clustered them hierarchically
so that model so that
they are clustered together according to
the similarity of the correlation of
these model prediction accuracies
uh but the structures of these
metabolites are are color-coded and what
you see is that though they've been
hierarchically clustered here the
different structures don't cluster
together right the greens are not
together
the blues are not together and so on
um and so that suggests that if you know
the structure of a particular metabolite
we're using this algorithm
encoded in the software classifier
that's not going to help you decide
which model to use
and then the last thing lauren has done
is use an annotation free similarity
of the different metabolites that's just
simply in the discovery panel
what is the genetic correlation in the
amounts of um
of this metabolite
and uh
so so we you know she calculates the
genetic correlations she uses that big
correlation matrix to do a hierarchical
clustering arbitrarily splits it out
into 10 groups
and what you find is that for the most
part uh
metabolites that are in the same
hierarchically clustered group have
high correlation of model accuracy with
each other
and and there's relatively lower
correlation of
model accuracy between two metabolites
that are in different
in different
um and this this is true for seven of
these ten clusters for the other three
there's a little bit of a head scratcher
mystery because um you know it seems
like
metabolites that are not in that group
have a higher correlation than than
metabolites that are within groups um
so
it's always good to have a little bit of
mystery um so the take-homes are from
this little vignette is that this this
approach that we're using of many-to-one
and prioritizing
rather than estimating
uh it has some merit i mean i think it's
helping us identify models that are more
predictive
uh and then sort of interestingly the
two extremes of the amount of
information that we have the amount of
biological information
are useful guides that is if you have
very detailed biological information you
have an actual compound annotation
you're good if you use this this
annotation free
method you're good and somewhere in
between uh the the sort of coarse grain
structure doesn't help you all that much
questions
all right so the next vignette is
yeah um so this is work that that mou
huang is doing it's on sugar kelp sugar
kelp has a biphasic life cycle
um and with both diploids and haploids
i'll just run through that what's the um
you know the kelp that you see along
this along the shore is a large diploid
individual it has reproductive tissue
source
uh from there you can express uh mayo
spores that can be sorted into 96 well
plates
uh these can grow up into gametophytes
which are haploid so diploid haploid uh
they are either male or female
you can increase the amount of tissue of
any given
haploid just by by breaking up these
clumps and they regrow
and you can cross them simply by
mixing vials that have a female and a
male together uh so these then then fuse
individual fused or actually
the male produces a sperm cell that that
goes and fertilizes the ovum in the
female
you get juvenile sporophytes you spray
those onto string you wrap the string
around ropes that are in these arrays
that are offshore
uh and now you again have a diploid you
can measure its growth and so on you can
evaluate you know the value of this
diploid for whatever purpose you know
food bio energy and so on
but the point is that uh
you know we evaluate these diploids but
our breeding germplasm
are these haploids okay uh we
we select among the haploids we um you
know we grow and we we just make
decisions about crossing the haploids so
we need to be able to share information
between the diploids and the haploids we
want to predict the breeding values of
the haploids we have information on the
diploids
it's not unlike what happens in dairy
cattle
you know folks evaluate cows what's
their milk yields but most of the
selection in dairy cattle happens on
bulls you can't measure milk yield on a
bull
uh
and so you need to be able to share
information between cows and bulls we
need to be able to share information
between diploids
so how do you do that
nice little bit of quantitative genetics
here
you start out with a
co-ancestry matrix
and you you want to conceptualize both
the gametophytes and the sporophytes in
terms of their haploid content so
i have four individuals two gametophytes
and two sporophytes the sporophytes take
up two columns and two rows because
they're diploid
the gametophytes take up just one of
each uh
you have ones on the diagonal so it's a
co-ancestor matrix matrix of
probabilities if you sample the same
allele from a half
from a haplotype twice you're always
going to get the same allele probability
one that you get the same allele
so now imagine
that uh this sporophyte one of its
parents is this first gametophyte so
this haploid is actually exactly the
same as this haploid and all of the
values in this row should be the same as
the values in this row okay
pretty straightforward the second parent
for this spore fight is some other
gametophyte and i'm going to imagine
that we know through pedigree or
whatever that it has some probability
point two of being related to this
getting to fight
uh
so anyway so that that generates another
row
second sporophyte i'm going to imagine
it's also
a progeny of this gametophyte and some
other gametophyte that's completely
unrelated so you know co-ancestry
probabilities of zero um and then this
gametophyte i'm gonna imagine it's the
progeny of this sporophyte and so to get
the the values in this row you just um
average out every
every cell or every um
every column in the two
rows for the sporophyte because
mendelian segregation there's probably
one half that it got this haplotype and
probably one half about that one
okay so that's nice that tells you how
to make a co-ancestry matrix but it's
not immediately helpful because we have
one
uh you know we have one observation for
a given sporophyte we don't have two
observations right
um we'd need an observation of somehow
the value of each haplotype here but we
just have one observation right so what
do you do
you do this highly technical thing of
condensing the coenzyme stream matrix
into a
haploid uh related
additive relationship majors haploid
reference additive relationship matrix
and you do that just by summing the
values that are in a particular cell so
uh 1 and 0.2 is 1.2 all this together is
2.4 etc
and this gives you what i call a haploid
reference additive relationship matrix
if you're thinking back to your
quantitative genetics and a typical
additive relationship matrix the maximum
value in a typical additive relationship
matrix is 2. here i have a value of 2.4
so it's a little different
what is that difference um
the difference is that in a in a
standard diploid uh additive
relationship matrix
you're using um breeding values of
variance among breeding values in other
variants among diploid additive effects
as the constant of proportionality right
to actually
uh
model the the distribution of these
breeding values
you need to multiply the additive
relationship matrix by a constant
proportionality
typically with a with a diploid
reference added relationship matrix
we're using these diploid reading values
here i'm using the variant of allelic
effects because i'm interested in
the gametophytes and they just have
single alleles uh
and so
you know the the variance of the single
alleles is about one half of the
variance of the diploid or is one half
of the variance of the diploid breeding
values and so the haploid reference
added relationship matrix has to be
twice as big as the
uh diploid reference additive
relationship matrix um
on the other hand we are evaluating
sporophytes and so if we want to get a
standard idea of the narrow sense
heritability of those sporophytes we we
take this constant proportionality and
double it in in the sort of standard
formula
okay so simple take home message for
this little
part of the talk is that uh it's
possible to predict reading values of
haploids on the basis of evaluations
from diploids and that's great because
it's going to enable us to do sugar kelp
breeding
um
good so now that you're thinking about
haploids and diphloids i'm on to mate
selection so
choosing which individual is going to
provide the the uh the pollen parent
haploid and which individual is going to
provide the seed parent haploid
and this is a masterwork of marnin in
his waning days as part of the next-gen
cassava project
so
starting from the very beginning
reading and how breeding works
we have two components to breeding we
have population improvement this is
recurrence you're
year after year making crosses that seek
to move
the distribution of the phenotypes or
the genetic values of your population in
a certain direction that you've decided
is superior
and then you have
what's you have variety development from
any given population where you know
you're just interested in identifying
the tales
for uh the recurrent selection part the
only thing that matters is the added
genetic variance um
for the variety development you know any
source of
overall total genetic value variance is
going to contribute uh so in particular
uh single locus dominance variants which
is what i'm going to be dealing with
here
i'm casting this in in what we now think
of as the two-part strategy of a
breeding program where you have a
recurrent selection more and more
frequently driven by
genomic predictions to accelerate the
breeding cycle and
from any given point in this recurrent
selection you spin off new variety
candidates
uh and they go into field testing
different stages of a variety
development pipeline
you get phenotypes from there those
phenotypes are important information for
reparametrizing the recurrent selection
or the the prediction models
okay
in the recurrent selection part
um each cross is an investment right
um you you know time land money
and the thing that we're interested in
is uh just identifying the tails among
the tragedy of your popular cross
consumer
okay
i'm not sure how to mute folks but uh
uh okay so so big investment
the only thing we care about is this
tail right
we want this tail as far out as possible
and
i can't i can't advance but
okay let's see if we can get back to
is are we back to
yes all right thank you mario
uh okay so so people have thought about
this for a long time you know breeders
have been around thinking quantitative
thoughts for a long time
uh so so
back in the 70s uh in germany they
developed this idea of
a usefulness criterion the usefulness of
a cross it's not just the mean value for
that cross it's what you expect when you
go out on the tail of that cross so
parameters in addition to the mean that
you need are um you know the the well
for breeding values you need
the added genetic variance or standard
deviation you also need to have some
sense of the selection intensity
um
and so now in assessing across we're not
just interested in the mean we're
interested in how variable are its
projects right
so
there's some quantitative genetics
figuring that out
but but note that
consistent with my two-part strategy
here i have two different kinds of
usefulness the one kind just involves
additive effects breeding values
and additive genetic variances and
but for varieties it's a total genetic
variance that matters um so i need a
sense of you know non-additive effects
that go into the mean
and non-additive effects that go into
the variance total genetic values
so
how does this work sort of from a
quantity of genetic perspective
first i'm thinking about parent one and
i'm worried just about reading values
for parent one
and i have to
know it's phasing
the reason i need to know it's phasing
is well you'll see in a moment it's not
necessarily relevant to the to the
reading value of the mean reading value
but um okay so i have it phased
and uh
i can calculate the mean breeding value
if i know
uh
the additive effects and now i'm
dividing them by two because i'm just
interested in this is a mean breeding
value for a gamete that comes from this
parent right
for the
variance among the gametes the breeding
values of the gametes what i need to
know is the linkages equilibrium between
the loci
of that that are contributing to the
breeding value
uh because so linkages equilibrium is
actually a covariance
the variance of a sum is the sum of the
variances plus the sum of covariances
so i need to have a sense of the
covariances among all the loci so these
are two different chromosomes
nicely
among gametes there's no covariance
among
loci on different chromosomes
likewise ld is very well behaved there's
almost no covariance between you know
extremes on the chromosome and it gets
high high covariance when you have low
side that are close together it turns
out there's a very nice formula if you
call this uh
disequilibrium matrix d1 for parent one
uh and you have the value of the effects
it's alpha transpose d1 alpha okay so
that gives a that gives me the variance
of of the effects of the gametes that
are produced by this parent
now
i can move on to the second parent and
you know conveniently this is why we
love additive genetic effects um you
know you can treat the second parent
completely independently of the first
parent do all the same stuff
phasing linkages equilibrium and so on
this uh
this equilibrium matrix is different
from this one because the allelic
content is different in this parent
it gets more complicated for the
dominance deviations
you can't you can't know what the
dominance deviations are going to be
from one parent independently of another
because it depends on you know the joint
uh inheritances
uh so you can get a mean total genetic
value from the probability of being a
homozygote versus the probability of
being a heterozygote here these are
dominance deviations you can get a
variance for the dominance deviations
with this somewhat more complicated
formula that requires knowing both of
the linkages equilibrium
covariance matrices but in the end
you have a variance for the total
genetic values this is just still single
locus
you have the sum of the variances from
the two gametes and some and the
variance that's due to the interaction
of the gametes
all right so what does this
uh what does this give you
uh sort of take homes
from um yeah from
mate selection uh the first thing that
it gives you is better breeding decision
support so
typically what we've always done is uh
just ranked different candidates based
on their prediction
but then the breeders still left trying
to decide which candidates to cross with
each other whereas now we're actually
going to be able to give you know
sets of crosses and how how good we
think they are and approximately how
many offspring you should want to try to
get at a particular cross so the breeder
you know has really good instructions
going into the crossing nursery
um the other thing that we hope to get
is greater gain from selection
so here's a figure from martin's paper
where we have 306 parents that's that
exists out in the field in nigeria and
ibadan
you can you can you can run
uh these analyses on many many different
pairwise processes right
306 times 305 divided by 2 something
along those lines
um
and
so
so this is a
figure that shows the relationship of
the usefulness for breeding value and
there and the usefulness for total
genetic value
um
for all of these crosses there's so many
crosses that the dots would be
overwhelming so it just has a contour
here um
and it's contrasted to 362 crosses that
have been previously made by the
breeding program
and what you can see is okay so we're
very hopeful but the the best crosses
that come from this prediction you know
are a good deal out ahead of um the
crosses that we've already attempted now
of course
here we're evaluating many many crosses
and
that means that that and we're picking
out the best ones so anytime there's
error associated with the prediction and
there is certainly in this case
and you you exert very strong selection
lots of what you're selecting on is the
error that you generated in your
analysis okay so as soon as we actually
make these crosses and look at their
tragedy we're going to be disappointed
relative to how good this looks here
but still
we have some reason to believe that
that you know this analysis is going to
come out ahead for us
questions
uh so yellow is is all prediction
empirical ones are these other colors
and and the the you know the purple over
the blue or the green are different
years in which they were made yeah and
actually the triangles are um selfs the
circles are crosses the the selfs
interestingly of course have just as
high reading value as the crosses but
they have lower total genetic value
because cassava suffers from inbreeding
depression
okay so the last bit
uh
is um bayesian optimization of breeding
schemes and i've actually done this with
a graduate student of peter frazier's i
know peter frazier is is the the guy
who's been doing the coven modeling for
cornell
turns out he's a runner so so i've gone
running with him and um and so i got to
talk to him and convince him that this
would be a fun thing for him to do i had
emailed him once a long time ago and he
didn't get back to me but you know once
your buddies like that it works so
he put it out to his lab and
his graduate student role la studio
has been helping me sort of figure out
the software
that that runs bayesian optimization
so why do we need this why do we need
some fancy
optimization approach
uh analytical models don't exist that i
know of so
just uh this sort of simple scenario
variety development pipeline you start
out with variety candidates you want the
best varieties possible this you can
analyze more or less analytic
decide
how you want to allocate your budget to
early mid late stage evaluations
and then in principle you take these
best varieties and you cross them to
start over again but of course we know
that response to selection
for unit time depends on how long the
breeding cycle is and this represents a
long breeding cycle so what you would
rather do is
take new individual individuals that are
just somewhere in the middle here
you know you haven't spent as much time
evaluating across them
but of course that means that these new
these individuals that you're going to
cross they now have to fulfill two
things just as before you're trying to
select them to create the best varieties
but at the same time you have to
maximize the improvement of parents
whereas for these individuals you're
still just doing the one thing so
in green you're trying to fulfill two
requirements in white just one and that
suggests the green is more important
which suggests that you might want to
change the geometry of the the overall
pipeline
and i don't know how to do that
analytically how to optimize this
analytically
so
um
so what does bayesian optimization do
it takes a continuous function and so
like the gain from selection over a
certain number of years is a continuous
function of of the parameters the
allocation parameters of your reading
program
it's useful when
evaluating this function is very
expensive
so in my case i'm simulating a breeding
program if i simulate a cartoon breeding
program i can do it minutes if i
simulate a realistic size one it takes
hours
so expensive to evaluate
uh
you don't observe any whoops any
derivatives
of f so derivatives are useful for
deciding how the slope is and how to go
up slope
and the last thing is often you observe
f with noise so in our case
when you simulate realistically this
whole thing you have errors associated
with evaluating the
the individuals you have uh random
mendelian segregation you have any
number of things that cause
one simulation to come out differently
from another simulation even if you
input the same initial parameters
so my parameters are uh budget
allocation so on the one hand i have how
much do i want to spend on the different
stages of the variety development
pipeline on the other hand i have how
much do i want to allocate to making
crosses and running you know genotyping
all of these individuals
and the population improvement uh side
okay so so just thinking again about
this and the problem that um bayesian
optimization solves i've i've run my um
my complicated simulation lengthy
simulation on a number of parameter
settings
and the problem is i can't decide which
direction is up from this i can't decide
which direction to go in
so where do i try next if i can't decide
where to try next one possibility would
be
to explore the whole space and then
smooth it out
and you know pick
some spot in the optimization space but
you know in the simple cases i'm going
to show you i have four parameters if i
do sort of a complete grid search of
that space it's really a lot of
function evaluations so
not
not really feasible
so um so this is the problem that
bayesian optimization solves is given
that i've evaluated the thing a few
times where should i look next uh so i
don't have to do a complete grid search
so here's how it works
the the trick
in the smart part clever about about
this is that okay i have this lengthy
complicated model i'm going to develop a
surrogate model
and the way it's going to work is it's
going to
model the outputs of the function the
root the true function as a multivariate
normal so it's very flexible and fast
so now i'm going to evaluate
run the breeding simulation a few times
i'm going to use the outputs that i get
from this to parametrize my surrogate
model i'm going to use the surrogate to
decide where to evaluate next
the technical term is i'm going to use
the surrogate to acquire the next
evaluation point that's called an
acquisition function
and then um evaluate f there now i have
some new values uh to use to parametrize
the circuit and i and i iterate and then
i'm gonna quit when i think um i've
stabilized at some maximum
so
just real quick
go ahead and let your eyes glaze over if
you want but um this is so so i said the
the surrogate model is multivariate
normal uh so imagine i've evaluated f
twice there's a covariance between these
two evaluations uh it's given by this
function sigma naught
and um here's one possibility for that
function
and basically what it does is it looks
at the distance between the the
parameter values and if the parameter
values are far apart
uh it gives a covariance that's close to
zero if the parameter values are close
together it gives the covariance close
to one
and it's actually for those of you who
are familiar with
genomic prediction models it's actually
quite similar to the reproducing kernel
hilbert space regression model
so familiar territory in some ways
all right
so the first problem i wanted to attack
was how many times do i have to run my
simulation model i did this with the
small scheme
uh you can sort of see some parameters
in here
i'm using cassava terminology so
seedling nursery clonal evaluation
trials preliminary yield trials and then
i send the best uh individuals or the
individual i think are the best to my
marketing department which is the
nationally coordinating trial
um i'm i always send four individuals
over there
so this is a sort of toy toy breeding
scheme
um and then on the recurrent selection
side i have uh
i'm imagining that i'm doing two cycles
per year of recurrent selection each
cycle has 100 progeny
these are the whoops
these are the error variances related to
the genetic variances so that you have a
heritability of about 0.1 about 0.2 and
about 0.3 as you move through the
variety development cycle the other
thing is costs matter here because i'm
optimizing for cost for a budget
uh the seedling nursery is where i
genotype individuals so growing the
seedling itself isn't so expensive but i
wanted genotype it
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
run i'm going to start with a given set
of founders i'm going to run independent
bayesian optimizations and when the the
optimizations agree with each other i'm
going to say okay i've reached a place
where um
yeah the models have stabilized
uh
no color
um
wow that's gonna be a problem if it's
like this in further slides
but
uh
okay so so
um
the way this is supposed to look is uh
okay so i have actually four budget
parameters that i'm interested in
optimizing i have the um
population improvement cycle the
seedling nursery and then the later
evaluation
stages and so uh any point in this
triangle sums to 1 or to 100 100
and what it's going to show you is
you know
well there should be yellow
for um high gain and all the way down to
purple for low gain
um this did not you can ask lauren this
did not look like this
yesterday
um
what a bummer okay i don't know what
happened
um
okay so so uh
all right whatever okay so what i did
here was i had three different founder
populations and i and i set off my my
two independent bayesian optimizations
on each founder population so founder
populations are in columns
and what what i noticed after 1500
iterations was you know this triangle
looked more like this one and now they
all look really similar
this this triangle would look more like
this one
than it would look like this one and
this one would look more like this one
than it would look so basically the the
the thing that we i discovered was that
um
this is going to be haha okay so it
doesn't show the colors but it shows the
red points which are the maxima
um
from each what i discovered was that the
overall landscape of gain i call these
triangles landscapes of gain was similar
but that the maxima didn't necessarily
you know fit together basically because
the the uh the fitness or the game
landscape is fairly flat at the maximum
uh and so you know here they match
pretty well but here not so much
uh and again here not so much like only
30
allocated to the
population improvement cycle versus you
know 42 percent
so the shape of the landscape would
match but the maxima didn't
okay
uh
what looks something like this
um and so so i sort of invented a
metric that showed the difference the
the distance between uh two um
two to gain landscapes so so here's one
gain landscape here's another one and
and i can calculate a distance between
these two so if i start with different
founders and i iterate my bayesian
optimization you know pretty pretty soon
it's it's
putting together
gain landscapes that are similar
but eventually that stops and then
interestingly if you start with the same
founder two different bayesian
optimizations it continues to sort of
fit
um
aspects that are particular to the set
of founders that you started with
uh but so i figure
since we don't actually know what the
characteristics of the founders are that
we have
i i'm thinking about 200 iterations is
good enough
when um you know the the landscapes that
started from different founders start to
look similar
okay next question
uh i mentioned that if you're just
trying to optimize the variety
development pipeline there's quick
analytical solutions for this
and so what i wanted to know is if i
optimize this vdp in the full context of
a two-part strategy how how much does it
look like
the optimization from an analytical
approach to the vdp
yeah just considered in isolation
and so here i'm doing this on a more
realistically sized breeding program
where the simulation takes you know two
or three hours to run
uh so i start with many more seedlings
and so on otherwise everything is the
same
uh and the recurrent selection is
cruising along with you know quite a bit
of effort
lots of progeny
and
uh okay well i'll just so
i'll just show you where the maxima are
um
and interestingly okay so they're
they're pretty different right when
when you uh optimize for the two-part
strategy which are these four somewhat
different triangles
um
you allocate a lot to the seedling
nursery where you're genotyping uh you
allocate almost nothing to this to the
final stage of evaluation
where um you know the in the final stage
of valuation is quite distantly related
to the individuals that are in the
recurrence election cycle
on the other hand you you have to invest
a fair amount in that final evaluation
if you're just considering optimality
for
the variety development cycle considered
on its own
okay
yeah
yeah per person so this is a percentage
of the budget that's going into the vdp
so this adds up to 100 and this adds up
to 100.
okay and then the last thing i wanted to
look at was differences between
a short-term
short-term gain versus long-term gain
and the basic idea here is over time you
have your population that's improving
but periodically you pull a set of lines
out and you do variety development on
them
um and so if you have a short time frame
the overall gain so you you start from
here and then you end up here the
overall gain is dominated by the right
development pipeline
you look at long-term gain again i'm
starting from here and i'm going all the
way to here
here the the difference is dominated by
how well my population improvement goes
okay so that would suggest that you need
to pay more attention to population
improvement if you want high long-term
gain
than if you want just short-term gain
right
and this is this is the saddest thing
okay so so anyway
uh
so i so my short-term gain was six years
my long-term gain was 12. i i feel it so
many people for long-term gain would go
longer than 12 philosophically i think
12 years is way beyond
how long you would use a single
rating scheme or single breeding
approach so what's the point of
optimizing a budget if it's if you're
going to change your breeding approach
halfway
and uh so so but what what tickled me
what what what i think is really fun
is that actually what happened was
uh the bayesian optimization is
suggesting that that i allocate more
budget for the short-term gain and less
budget for the long-term gain or
actually more correctly that when i want
high long-term gain i need to invest a
lot in the phenotype
because the phenotypes at the end of the
day are still the quantum of information
that moves that generates accuracy for
your genomic prediction model if you
don't have the phenotypes
your your genomic prediction model what
it's going to do here is it's going to
run through
a lot of
a lot of the variability and there won't
be variability left for long term
here if you invest in the phenotyping
you're maintaining a higher level of
accuracy and you're reducing the the
loss of
genetic diversity
so so interestingly even though what i
want to do is prioritize in this long
term the population improvement cycle
what that suggests is that i have to
invest in the thing that makes the
population improvement cycle work and
that's those are the phenotypes
okay so take homes uh first of all
interestingly the founding population
itself
has some characteristics that affect
optimal allocation i'm not sure there's
much we can do with that because
you know i just don't know what aspects
of the founder population matter or how
to measure them in practice
uh i think about 200 simulations should
be good enough i mean that'll vary from
scheme to scheme but but it's an order
of magnitude
um
analyses that optimize the vdp alone you
can do them analytically they're fast
but they don't necessarily give a good
guide
and interestingly maximizing for
long-term gain requires more phenotyping
because you want to maintain the
accuracy of your genomic prediction
model and usually on my mac anyway it
generates pretty pictures but not so
much here
um
all right and that's everything i have
to tell you
and
so i'm not i think this is probably the
end of uh
of our time i'm not quite sure when is
it supposed to end
but so if folks need to leave i know i
know that there's um
uh 40 80 is happening over in the field
house so
huh
115 okay
okay well anyway so we have some time
for questions
well right i mean i think i think
typically
right you you would use uh
the set of founders that have some level
of diversity where also you expect
you know positive dominance deviations
in in crosses among those founders yeah
you can try to select out those founders
i think even if you did that there would
be differences between
you know different sets that that have
something to do say with the level of ld
between causal loci
that you can't measure uh because you
don't know where those causality are
um and i think those types of things
affect the variance in ways that the
optimization picks up on but that you
you know you can't get a handle on uh
initially
well um
oh repeating the question right so
uh
selection intensity
isn't the only determinant
um
you know the number of of individuals
that you're looking at matters because
it changes the probability that you're
going to identify a superior segregate
and um well you know i would say my my
complex function that the bayesian
optimization is is working with
you know models all that it it models
random mendelian segregation it models
random recombination breakpoints it
models linkages equilibrium among loci
so
yeah one way or another is going to take
that into account and that's why it
takes you know three hours to run one
simulation
and why i want to minimize the number of
simulations i have to do to get a sense
of
my budget allocations
uh so it'll it'll you know the the
you know
the major challenge it turns out for
using this bayesian optimization at
least for me is that it's in python and
i'm comfortable with r and getting r and
python to work together is not easy
um
and uh
so so my joke about this is that uh so
you know the bayesian optimization it
optimizes a function that's a black box
so you have this python thing that's
querying an r based black box
but the black box accounts for all of
these things that you're thinking about
mark
well
well
um that's a good question i haven't
actually you know like this is hot off
the presses
um so so i haven't talked about it with
folks in in nigeria i think one of the
important features to remember about
this
is that at the maximum you have a fairly
flat
gain landscape so there's options for
doing a lot of different things and
still having it work pretty darn well
and i sort of liken this to to yield
components where you know
you might yield components you estimate
in having more tillers per unit area but
then you have fewer you know grain heads
per tiller
or pure
uh scenes per tiller something like that
likewise here you know if you invest
more early you invest less late but you
know invest more you know whatever you
still have i mean what matters
ultimately is your budget um and there
are optima to be found and i think there
are
sort of take-home messages about what
not to do i mean like in particular you
don't want to invest too little in the
stage where you do the genotyping
because the genotyping stage is what
feeds your prediction model right if you
have a small
uh
yeah if you have a small set of
individuals who are genotypes you can't
have high accuracy um likewise
uh one of these things showed if you
invest a ton
in the population improvement cycle that
means that you have very little in your
phenotyping and it crashes sort of
immediately i mean these are like
but um anyway the bayesian opposition
administration picks up on that
yeah
okay uh you indicated that the optimum
for breeding progress was fairly flat
yeah
do you think that holds up if so
progress will be pretty robust changes
in student talents grant funding
non-funding and other unmodeled factors
okay that's pretty interesting
um
well okay so grant funding or
non-funding that doesn't work because
you know a flat
model at the top doesn't mean that you
can take away from the budget and still
have it work right
so then then student talents i'm looking
at a very narrow set of parameters here
i'm looking at
um you know how much to invest in the
different stages
and i'm not looking at how carefully the
the student is is doing their work or
you know whether indeed you're you're
doing a good job of trying to select for
traits that have heritability as opposed
to investing a lot of selection effort
in traits that that you would really
like to have but they have very low
heritability i mean something has very
low heritability it doesn't matter how
important it is to you it's not going to
help you to invest a lot of effort in it
so
thinking along those lines uh i i think
now at this at the same time
my statement i'll defend it by saying if
you if you go out there and you look at
the world of wheat breeding
the wheat breeders do a lot of different
things right they don't all have the
same uh breeding program
and so i think part of the reason why
that still seems to work is because yeah
a lot of different things work you know
i'm sure there's there's an optimum and
that's determined here at cornell
uh
vote for me
but um anyway a lot of things
any other
questions yeah
yeah i think you could do that that's
sort of interesting so for example in
the in the cassava project
we've invested a fair amount of effort
in developing near-infrared spectroscopy
so that's a technological innovation
what the technological innovation does
is it allows you to phenotype more
individuals
somewhat less accurately right
is that a is that an allocation that's a
good idea or not
and what's cool about this bayesian
optimization is it doesn't it's it's
optimizing a black box it doesn't care
what the what the parameters are
so
uh you know i mean you don't want to
have 30 different parameters that you're
trying to optimize
i started with four i'm sure i can go up
to you know seven or eight or nine and
and i think those ideas like like so
martin might use this in in in the mate
selection like how much are you going to
emphasize usefulness
for reading value versus usefulness for
total um
genetic value or you know another thing
that matters a lot in long-term
selection versus short-term selection is
what is the effective population size
that you maintain in your current
selection population so you can add that
as a parameter um
right so
yeah
i mean that's one of the cool things
about this approach is that i think it's
robust to
lots of different possibilities
i think there was
yeah carl
well yeah i mean i think the the black
box that you optimize you can make that
black box as complicated as you want to
you know there's trade-offs in that
right the the rule of thumb for models
is
you want the model to be
as simple as possible
as long as it captures you know the
phenomenon of interest so
make it only as complicated as it needs
to be to capture the interaction that
you care about
and no more complicated so so for
example i started out by programming a
simulation model that included checks
and it turns out adding checks to a
simulation model is kind of a pain in
the neck and it makes it a lot more
complicated i mean it's not a huge
complication but in hindsight i was like
well you know the checks we're not
really using them in assessing in in the
simulation in the simulation i don't
simulate any kind of spatial variability
or whatever because you know whatever
this is a long long discussion but
yeah that was wasted effort
um
in real life in reality you need checks
yeah
i'm not disputing that
and and and maybe you know
if you wanted to start to model spatial
variability or more complex dbi
interactions where you might be able to
assess something about the environment
based on the checks that you had
yeah then you would want to put checks
in there
because it would allow you to do that
but otherwise don't
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu